fake news and fast food that is the
subject of tonight's waters words the
media Research Center conducted a study
of the network newscast coverage of the
trump presidency in 2018 a tone of the
coverage 90% negative and just 10%
positive take the fast food story this
week as a perfect example
Clemson won the BCS Championship and was
invited to the White House as is
customary because of the shutdown there
weren't any White House chefs to prepare
dinner for the player so the president
catered it himself I had a choice do we
have no food for you because we have a
shutdown or do we give you some little
quick salads that the first lady will
make along with along with the second
lady they'll make some salads and I said
you guys aren't into salads or do i oh
go out Lindsey Graham and Tim Scott do I
go out and send out for about 1,000
hamburgers we have Big Macs we have
quarter pounders which is we have
everything that I like that you like now
the players loved it and if you just
look at their social media pages it's
true they went back for seconds and had
a blast but the negative media they
didn't like it at all he thinks he's
being so slight normally I would have a
salad for dinner on Monday but they told
me they only eat every fast-food what's
he's paying the check so he had to get
the cheapest food they could find is it
possible you're just protecting your
favorite foods on to them we can eat all
of their favorite foods burgers KFC taco
balls two scoops of ice cream
we're gonna watch their favorite movie
the 2016 election results in fact one
host on ESPN said serving fast food to
football players is racist when I saw
him giving the football players it's a
predominantly black sport and fast food
my thought would win a very different
place whoa where did it go
let's look back in how President Obama
liked fast food remember he likes pies
and ice cream all that stuff here's
Barack Obama making a run to Five Guys
to feed the White House staff
you a hamburger I do two burgers for
breakfast
[Laughter]
and look how the media covered Obama in
fast food the Washington Post's
President Obama and cheeseburgers a love
story the double standards don't stop
there
Republican congressman from Iowa Steve
King made a shocking comment to the New
York Times saying he didn't understand
why the phrase white supremacist was
offensive no I don't know if he was
taken out of context by The Times but
everybody agrees that's very bad but
MSNBC they spun his comments this way
this does not have a parallel on the
left they're just just it doesn't there
isn't there isn't a strain of racism on
the Left there's not now the truth is
both parties have problems on their
fringes to deny that is to condone it
the far left certainly has an
anti-semitism problem here the Jews
don't like Farrakhan so they call me
well that's a good name it was a very
great man call me an anti-semite
stop it I'm auntie termite and Farrakhan
by God's grace has pulled that seat whoa
and here's Farrakhan posing with Barack
Obama this was a picture the media
suppressed before his election and
here's Maxine Waters hugging the Nation
of Islam leader Wow
furthermore these comments by a CNN host
those offended a lot of people watch
this we have to stop demonizing people
and realize the biggest terror threat in
this country is white men most of them
radicalized right not to the right and
we have to start doing something about
them white men are the biggest threat to
America all right and then there's the
language I gotta get to Nebraska more
you're welcome we'd love to have your
work of the fields with us working this
part of that Senate I'm a house there
are white I've seen a lot of white might
I'm gonna use that word those were
Antipa protesters yelling that at ice
agents by the way in conclusion if Trump
serving whoppers at the White House is
racist but schmoozing with Louis
Farrakhan is acceptable then we're never
going to be able to have an honest
discussion in the media about the real
issues of discrimination in America